two what what do you like to do with it
whatever
a woman will let me do oh so oh do to
her whatever a woman will let you do to
her i'm not really into
getting my balls stepped on okay so not
a sub
well
i don't know dude
um
okay
so you're a dog you're dumb cow well it
sounds weird to have a dog but it's like
isn't that the most least creative
position like everyone wants to be a dog
no no no i i love to be a self all right
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah actually
i uh
i was telling my dad that i broke up
with my boyfriend and was like
he's like what are you sad yeah i'm
pretty sad well you're not just because
you're gay doesn't mean you're a robot i
was like i didn't think i was a robot
dad
yeah
getting gay lessons from your
conservative dad yeah you did your
is your dad christian
yeah did he ever read the book that's
like women no love and respect
then love respect and women love love
and my dad was telling me about this
book because i don't know how it would
work for you
respect or respect or something
yeah like that one song i love respect
not respect and respect exactly
that's too much respectful you know
that's what they say about the gays
gentleman it's like a [ __ ]
featherweight fight with you guys you
know you guys are both in the same
weight class and for domestic violence
oh no
i like to be like a
like a att that's how i like it if a
bigger dude and me or me in a smaller
so it's never
straight all the way across nope i've
never kissed a man eye level
well i'm learning a lot i
am really happy that uh you know this is
the sex thing that i should have gotten
all my years in christian education but
uh you know even if you're in a
relationship you still sign up you know
it doesn't mean you have to [ __ ] with
dude you're just going on like a
symbolic date
so really no no strings attached if
you're a woman you're coming up and you
signed up this is you because there's
only one it's rony
rooney
caleb
caleb
[Music]
makes way more sense
rony sounds like pepperoni
here we go that's right another brave
contestant here we go ronnie and caleb
hi ronnie how's it going
i like these uh synthetic dates have you
been on one before
yeah what made you sign up tonight
is
um
[Music]
uh where are you from are you from
austin
oh cool i spent some time in uh dodge
city
oh okay okay so you are from austin cool
yeah did you ever make it out to dodge
wider country
okay
yeah well
austin
uh
oh i thought you were going to say
clothing
very cool
uh i'm a man about town i'm a layvo
you know i just hang out
a bad usual
yeah
um
yeah that's what i appear to do
not originally i'm a transplant like so
many others uh i came in last year so
i've been here about a year now
uh are we still in cloven i don't know
are we are we still in copenhagen and
time give it up for kayla asking the
audience uh
epidemiological question
uh caleb you said you're a man about
town yeah and then ronnie just was like
nah i don't need to know
i don't remember you from austin
are you a [ __ ] that's what it means
right yeah you lay about town you go
from hole
yeah i believe the technical term is
gigolo
so that's your job that's what i'm
trying to break into now so you mean
you're unemployed
yeah but you don't want to say that no
job caleb
break into that i don't know i'm just
you know i just i just figure you just
put the intention out there
or god whatever you know incomes income
yeah we're all people all humans are
here
so you said that you uh
you know man about town lay around a lot
or something
and do you get money from this how do
you live not yet uh
desperately i suppose you could say
and uh ronnie you said you're a designer
and then you qualify that with the
graphic designer usually
usually uh you know you meet with the
computer part or whatever but you're
like yeah i design things in the
vr world
that's cool
uh you know that's that's we are in
austin so we should have assumed that
any designer would bit of the graphic
variety
do you use like photoshop illustrator
sketch
there you go
i did i used to do ui design back in the
day
i'm trying to break into gigolo dome
anything can happen in america yeah
right
i just feel like it's not that hard to
break into and so i'm just wondering why
you're downloading it
do you have tips and tricks
be
you know have a website probably would
help uh your ux designer so i'm sure you
got a good one you guys actually could
go together you could design his
you know if you in fact if you were
gonna if you were gonna design a logo
for his gigolo thing what would it be
i mean you would want to leave with a
johnson right unless i was like a hidden
paywall type cinch
yeah
and a qr code that you could scan
that leads you to a booking page
this is like a 14 year old's fantasy
about what a man should look like
it's all going together now ronnie so uh
you're here on a date with another man
yes how did you meet this particular
gentleman
i was uh we were in the same graduate
school class and i was house gotten back
and he thought he should speak to me
you decided not to sue him
and now you're dating him
full time
actually oh [ __ ] the ultimate date
did he wake you up like he wakes up now
um no
i would be waking up then
then yeah people like hey they do are
you sleeping
i was like let's go get more drinks
you were passed out drunk
yeah
ears fairly hot it was a night
hey do whatever you want that's why i uh
i i don't drink anymore so i just
encourage everybody else to get really
[ __ ] up
get a drink for a cold temple you got a
drink for two men
that's what they say when you get
pregnant mm-hmm
are you gonna have jesus
maybe
no not yet so would you pay
this man to go out on a date again like
he's now working in the business but so
if say your husband's like i don't have
time for valentine's day and you were
like don't worry there's a service for
that would you go
i mean you would be his first paying
customer but
would you go
he's usually an early adopter
you're getting in on the beta version of
caleb i got a 20
yeah 20 discount for the beta version
some early bursts where that price act
well what did they charge thousand
dollars hey it's
parents
maybe if you pay extra he'll blink on
the day yeah
just some kind of thing
so ronnie what uh
so you you started dating your husband
right out of college so you congratulate
grad school which is like extra college
so you love school and just get enough
of it a team yeah that's what you did
what does your husband do
professionally um
he
does
content strategies and marketing and
video
stuff i can use
so you guys are you guys on the field
fielder
the older
uh
yeah he's playing the field if i can
make a living
yeah might be your clap
yeah
what's your preferred dating strategy do
you go on tinder or do you prey on
people in person
uh yeah sometimes i'm crazy prowl
conflicting person just depends on the
mood but uh i like the dating apps
because you can give a little background
info
i learned about your victim and you
learn about your victim what's the last
day you've been on
uh
actually recent real date last sunday
last sunday one week ago and how did it
go this is not a real day
well i don't know i mean your parents
here's my first
[Music]
i invited her i said
we should see top gun
she was like hurry up
i think it's amazing
if you like the guy then you see it
again i think it's enough you don't see
it again i don't see it again
no i don't know but i [ __ ] watch a
movie twice that i kind of like for
anyone really okay that's not sanders
that's nice i feel like
you know are you are you gonna vote
nonetheless i really like tom cruise
yeah in that case she did she's not that
into she's in the tom cruise yeah
there's so many more movies that we
could see
that if you're gonna do that to me if
you're gonna do that to me on my second
they [ __ ] you up the red flag out
yeah yeah well i mean i do love tom
cruise so it's just suggested as an
indie film something that she probably
hasn't seen before
like harry potter
that's brand new yeah which was [ __ ]
by the way i'm not gonna go see that
movie again either did they have a new
one now is there a new one yes oh
fantastic beasts dumbledore's secret
secret is he's gay but i don't get to
see anything anything i want to see some
magical spells i'm just like ass [ __ ]
you don't get to see it
[ __ ] i just figured you hit a joint
you go to the movies how's that about i
gotta put that one out on the pornhub no
it's just my imagination have you ever
read the hunger games yeah i love the
hunger
games how you had to imagine all the
murder and then you didn't get to see
much murder in the movies yeah that's
how books work yeah
right but that's how harry potter was
with this too oh it's like they don't
it's like jaws they don't show you the
juicy details yeah so you have to
imagine
well i can just do that at home i don't
have to pay 20 bucks to imagine
dumbledore [ __ ] a wizard
out there
it's kind of close right
so ronnie what's like your favorite type
of form to watch
with your husband of course
well actually with and without is it the
porn you make yourself
yes
the way you watch yourself [ __ ] i'm
asked sorry is that a confusing question
okay
answer is that narcissism or is that
just learning i don't know that's what i
was gonna assess
these
scenes it's all of us tonight
please don't laugh with a microphone
ronnie so like
have you have you had a like a
crazy
crazy sort of like swinger proposition
ever between you and your husband
any upside down pineapples
what is that a thing yeah upside down
pineapples means you're a sweater oh i
thought they was exerting somewhere
like a terrible text stitch
uh
experience
[Music]
why is that
why why do straight people feel like
they have to be so monogamous
okay that's fair
that's fair
i mean that's bigger
this can be nerve-wracking
maybe your husband spilled this and you
guys can watch it back later yeah
it's gonna be on youtube right
yeah
it's okay yeah
it's currently out on youtube right now
yep
sweet
yeah this is uh how kayla makes this
money apparently
kayla so uh so gigolowing is going good
for you uh
what uh what do you think about austin
where is the best place to go on a date
if you were to take ronnie on another
date where would you take her
uh
like a week ago well what's your
preference do you like restaurants bars
food food
food and drink uh
bruce brisk like a good steak
it's the most generic steakhouse in the
world
you know it's comforting it's not a red
lobster but yeah it's not far off right
but it's comfort it's like a it's
acceptable it's like olive garden for
upper class of the civil counsel yes
i think we can do better than that
what's your favorite restaurant out here
what's your proteins um
for a date i think it would be fun to go
to
just gonna pick first
high noon have a cocktail i needed the
topping truck that's in front of it
texted me now that sounds really good
i went to the roosevelt room
at the she couldn't be born
that's the whitest thing you've said so
far yeah because i think you said
roosevelt
not a little platonic hug just now
and we're going to get another date a
lot of women signed up hopefully
consensually and a lot of dudes said
that they're women
uh but welcome to everyone who came late
uh i don't know where you guys were at
but uh
welcome
jasmine moody baby
coming on i love that crowd is in
hysterics
you can sign up anytime please sign up
uh jasmine moody and jessie gill
matching
what
looking at the name of each other
they came together
and go
with the mics to your mouth
timmy
[Music]
a little bunch of times all right i'm
going to ask you anything oh you don't
know
tacos
well first you gotta ask for the green
sauce
[Music]
he said toppings
maybe rita wrote
do y'all know where restaurants have
burritos at
night invest all the burritos
that's just the wildest thing you said
tonight no i said i've seen harry potter
at least five times
i don't think that
typically counts as a sit-down
restaurant
that's uh take it home and blow up the
toilet after
and time
for jasmine and jesse
that's why they came together real
fireworks going off between
do you like to talk about eating tacos
on a date you know men can take that the
wrong way
it means
yeah if you ever met your taco eating by
jesse
how did you consider talking
well
i'm sure you can get a lot of red sauce
just didn't go at that time of the month
very insects someone just came right now
someone just had an orgasm picturing me
eating jasmine
so uh you guys are mexican or not
not punjabi
you're one good job punjabi
japanese
[Music]
i think that's called an arranged
marriage
hopefully a range is just a marriage and
not a uh kill room
uh but uh how did you guys meet
jasmine and jassy
we was on flights
it was your what blood what's going on
for what
heroin taco
heroin whatever you do here
i want them to cradle me i said why
injured got some big nurse arms
as long as you're ready to get a foley a
foley
[Music]
as a kid very convenient people are like
oh no all right i have to go
it's great
i can do it right now if i could but
they won't let me back in the building
okay
so you guys uh met he was your drug
dealer and now he's so nervous this is
going out on youtube by the way no no no
no
i was a nurse in her drug dealer okay
i really know my parents don't see this
the chances are small i think
[Music]
how long have you guys been together
did you guys set them up you guys seem
very invested in their world their
parents
that's your best friend
are you guys also punjabi
love
we lost the broadway show wow that's
pretty white
yeah i fell asleep
she was hot that's why
maybe she was getting uh foley from here
uh
have you guys met each other's parents
yet
no
who who is more afraid to be the other
one's parents who has the worst parents
he pointed at you
and i don't know if that means i don't
know if that means you are the worst
ones or
my parents would be
more
protective okay yeah you're dating a
nurse could be dating a doctor yeah
he said
because they're very different and
that's i've always said that they're
very different
hindus and punjabis
sick people pronounce
to them
if that's one of them
that's okay jeff jesse gets when he goes
eat your tacos gets a little sick
but uh jesse uh what do you uh what's
the craziest thing you've seen as a
nurse have you ever had to put a bully
in someone's [ __ ] or something
no that's called the rectal tube and
i've done that too whoa
nice i mean it's gay pride month i'm
sure yeah i was gonna say like is it
convenient so
would one casually get that you just
gotta loop it up enough and it's
convenient for anybody then so could you
say hook it up if i was to have like a
very special day with a group of men or
something i would go to you and you
do what i want maybe that hospital great
[ __ ] yeah i got your dog like don't
forget i was the plug
what i'm asking is do i want an anal
rectal tube or do i want like a like uh
just some
like a douche or something i don't know
you tell me
you want to want a rectal tube
no
it's so far up there or what no you go
up to the sphincter about to the
second
notch that that [ __ ] stays in it don't
come out
forever
no i like telling you know you wake up
and you're like oh pull this [ __ ] out
but for the most part it's in there okay
now put rubbing that knuckles on their
penis
your [ __ ] notifications no uh so
that's great what uh what's the craziest
thing you've seen in the in the er or
wherever you want my senior nurse okay
it's crazy [ __ ] huh
besides you just shot in the head before
someone got shot at the head yeah then
he got pissed off that he was in the
hospital the bullet fell out the other
way
so he got lodged in and then he got
pissed and his blood pressure went up
and the bullet fell out
i ain't playing with jesus that's a good
way to get the bullet out exactly you
know he saved about 15 20 grand on
surgery but it went out the other side
afterwards well he tried to shoot
himself because his girlfriend broke up
with him yeah and then he [ __ ] missed
so it just got lost right there in
school and then it came back out the
same way oh it came out the other way so
the hole was still here from the low
back of it
oh yeah i love that you always have to
remember blow back oh you gotta be
splash guard and [ __ ] right uh-huh are
you a nurse too
what's the craziest [ __ ] you've ever
seen
i'm the 19 person
this is a simple like it's the craziest
line of code that's everything
you talk to people as a coder
i don't care
[Music]
what's your favorite thing about jesse
he's a cheering person
yeah that's his job he gets paid for
that
so you believe when he says no i care i
care
sometimes what's some [ __ ] that he does
not care about whenever you're talking
you're like oh he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about this
is it the taco thing probably about you
for some of the things i say like what
every god doesn't care
wow you've never met jesus
i mean i don't know if that's
there's a secret that can't [ __ ]
listen to anything you say seriously
well you rejected 90 of the time in 10
what'd you say
okay
you're going to be great when you're
like 60 years old
you're just trying to get the bullet out
of your head
it's trying to piss you off for the
better event of your health
uh jesse what's your favorite thing
about jasmine
she keeps it real so
[ __ ] up she tells me straight up on the
spot yeah
you put the fully in the wrong hole
[ __ ] exactly
she says he forgot to loop it up enough
are you circumcised
no
he is intact no sikhs have sick dicks
uh you clean it out a lot you uh you you
know i mean i'm a nurse it's all about
hygiene right yeah maybe not your own
fooling yourself
huh
do you never put it hide anything in
there if only we're that big oh okay
damn
wow i just imagine i'll put like pills
and whatnot in there
skittles maybe i don't
know
can you imagine just like oh we want a
mint is there anybody's having it
whatever your tacos making bread sauce
and you just could have been in there
jesse what's uh what's the craziest
thing that you've seen on a date like
before you met jasmine it's like is
there like a date that stands out as
some craziest thing or like
just something here is like oh i can't
believe i i went on the second date
right i did i went back
just trying to think of something that i
won't get to yell at tonight she's a
smart man
i think she yells i think she mumbles
madly
i believe you did that funny way i'm
gonna read my book now
i'm gonna watch harry potter without you
with my headphones up and she's gonna
eat the twelve don't forget
what you said she said she's gonna eat
her chipola while she's watching harry
potter she's gonna eat her
chipotle because you guys are gonna be
in
yeah i have stomachs
tonight what's the best indian
restaurant here
your mom's house
or his mum's
haven't been to
either but you mean his mom's house you
said you haven't met her yet uh-huh
okay well look at him
he's well-fed
oh okay
i'm gonna get that away with mcdonald's
and some nice korean
chicken tikka masala
uh so what do you think about the uh you
know india china border or over there
smacking each other with sticks or
whatever i think nepal's getting the
worst of it both ways as the paul's
getting a fully tube in both holes
fully indirectly to both sides
that's cool what's the next step in your
guys's relationship
what's the next step i think it's
probably going to be parents meet the
parents
what is that going to be in austin
no he's from dallas okay
houston okay
so i'll each other singles it's getting
this probably
yeah i don't know
okay
we'll just let her play you don't you
give him whatever
it's gonna take forever
but they're not they're not white but
they're not happening
if they're not happy
[Music]
they're very helpful
yeah that's the way to do it
i wish someone would arrange your
marriage for me
yeah there's one i'd like that
what there's websites for that website's
gonna
so the website arranges it for me
yeah
[Music]
yeah i've heard of that
are you just talking about tinder or
what
yeah that's one of them okay
is really great
jesus christ i this is not an arranged
marriage that's just meeting new people
oh there's some race
well the arrangement would be colten
gets to not work ever again because he
married a very very rich top very
important
okay so that you guys don't have like a
what does it call the judaism the
matchmaker
a rabbi yeah no it's not
hard work whatever
okay you guys don't have that
do you guys have like a community oh you
guys have didn't do a rage marriages
you're wrong there
is your parents race parish yes sir
whoa
and you guys are just unarranging it you
guys are just like going out there
[ __ ] anything do they think you're
saying they're like oh my god dating is
crazy
well back in the day that was a cultural
norm so nowadays it's not so much
not even improved driving land punjabi
that's much worse than here
so they still arranged back there no
they [ __ ] like wild
beer
well i'm sure that you know there's a
billion of you guys you guys it's not
like you guys are celibate
we're the fourth and the fourth largest
religion in the world
okay
your fake [ __ ] is pretty popular
um i am an atheist
and i'm not in kindergarten and i have
an internet connection
uh but uh what's your favorite thing
about the seats you guys do have that
nice you guys carry on a knife and slice
up people that try to steal your tax
caps
okay
k-i-r-p-e-a-n
what is it used for
circumcision
oh [ __ ]
what's the craziest thing that you've
seen in punjabi food job
siri was already looking for you huh
she found nothing i didn't understand my
question sorry
have you been to
what he's calling footjob lives
sounds like a magical campaign it's so
fun it's awesome i mean
wait you've never been and you're like
oh they're over there [ __ ] where did
you go
2014.
how old are you now 27.
19.
19 watching people [ __ ]
wishing you were arranged to be in one
of those [ __ ] circles
so
i mean that's cool you know um you're
welcome
do you guys think it's to work out
we'll see
yeah i think so are you guys going to do
the monogamous thing
i mean that's so exciting that's step
out of time they're just coming out of
arranged marriages yeah i wanted to be
[ __ ]
dudes and chicks and stuff and yeah it
sticks and
what where you got them to do a toy
player
okay so it could be he could be using a
dildo oh how do you like it so big
tonight isn't it
i'm circumcised tonight
uh but thank you uh jasmine and jesse
for coming on stage and following that
day
after a real couple
who's actually gonna [ __ ] tonight
we've got another woman coming up her
name happens to be
momisha
here we go
coming on
[Music]
oh a stairs over there
and the lord wrapped her way up in the
street
following her
future impoverisher
all daily overall future cop wasn't
david alicia punjabi
are you also on a date
i am on a date say i'm sorry
that's funny are you on the date no i'm
just here well now we are yeah
[Music]
no i'm from outside of philly
okay what brought you to texas um
it's just a lot of [ __ ] in this video
where are you from here i'm from houston
texas
oh wow
wow you guys just lost the women's
softball championship didn't i don't
keep that
to your face
on twitter oh you did wow what was your
name
oh wow what about you
i was a communications i dropped out i
don't know if you can tell with my
outfit
yeah
fine so like when he is are you good
with like taxes and [ __ ]
that's not fair
[Music]
talk to an educated woman for the first
time in his life
and tunisia
a ut grad a proud texan
and uh confusing white people for other
white people in connor
you know this is a crapshoot connor and
chad rayden and to be fair
i do love this show that you're bringing
two people who never [ __ ] ever across
past
but literally a person of you know you
have your [ __ ] together you you must
know about taxes and some [ __ ] [ __ ]
and the guy who doesn't know that that's
an accountant wouldn't do taxes
financial uh it seems in his numbers
i'll give you that
i'm consultant financial consultants
definitely
i mean
any city bring my laptop and technically
be working 40 hours a
don't have to stack bricks that you do
in philadelphia
i was amazing
communications
i didn't think
just the only reason i know the
difference okay and then i went to their
school
and then i came out so
okay well i i cut hair too so i guess so
it was at least a few years off
you said you came to austin for a lot of
reasons does that mean you're currently
you have a warrant out for your arrest
in philadelphia i mean i don't think so
i mean
no no
so bought all that jewelry legitimately
no i inherited everything that the
bracelet the necklace are fake i was
thinking of finance 10 bucks on amazon i
know how to get a good deal wow give me
the finance degree yeah
um
but uh yeah what's uh what's your what's
your uh
what you came here for uh stand up
comedy maybe yeah
he didn't want to say
uh
is actually a very funny stand-up
comedian does that is a sense of humor
something that you look for in a man
you see some people don't finish college
yeah
and i don't know if you know this
communications is the easiest major you
can have yeah at ut i think that's the
major goats but we can't get into
anything else
that's some funny thing because most
people that do communications are
athletes but he's this
i'm [ __ ] cool
he's cool what's up what's something
physical that you can do right now that
might have pressed monesha
i don't see where it's here
i do it okay shut the [ __ ] up i got
really big caps they like to make fun
before they see them they say i have
like special ed casts holy temple yeah
wow who's saying
everybody in the austin comedy scene is
like put your [ __ ] legs away
you've got a freak yeah can let's see
him it's there oh okay
why don't you step on the center stage
and flex do a little tippy tail yes we
see like a muscle man competition have
you heard of muscle manchester united
okay
what does standing bricks will get here
you don't get that tapping away on a
laptop in any city in the world yeah
drop out after two years and you could
give me something i'll tell you what
how did they get so big
oh it's alternate my brothers had him
too my dad
i don't know why are counts good for
something
no i can't drink like [ __ ]
punjabi's worship calves
do they exactly
no
that's hindus yeah oh yeah
they're completely different
oh nice how do you say you have big cavs
in punjabi
then
that means sister [ __ ]
uh if you have a sister i mean you're
white you might [ __ ] your cousin just
like extra water brothers two older
brothers do they have to [ __ ] you or no
they're
just alcohol what's the biggest thing
yeah good point how do you say brother
[ __ ]
[Music]
what's the meanest thing your brothers
ever did to you
okay so like me and my middle brother we
kind of formed an alliance really young
against cavalry
so like we would [ __ ] with him but like
the actual meanest [ __ ]
i guess this thing
i mean i i think i did mostly i think
that was the problem
we never said you weren't the problem
what's the uh like did they ever hurt
you you're like how that hurt brother um
okay no so they didn't do it to me but
my middle brother one time so my oldest
brother was seven years older than me
and uh he had a buddy over when they
were like 13. they were playing like
wolfo ball in our backyard from metal
baseball that and my other brother
wanted to play and they were like [ __ ]
out of here like you're you know [ __ ]
[ __ ] you so they can't be a [ __ ]
you're trying not to say that where it
is i'm i've been in middle school too
i've been to school
and then my little brother wanted to
play and they were like no so he grabbed
the bat and threw it like helicopter
style and they cracked my other
brother's head open and we had to like
go get like
an ambulance
that's gonna be
what's their first club philadelphia
yeah is that all right yes that's what
it means why are there batteries outside
philadelphia means
brotherly love
manisha do yeah have any siblings i do
i'm the oldest you're the oldest yeah
that's younger brother you've ever
thrown a cricket bat at some point
i became your sister also she's seven
years older
and you've been completely that's a
large age gap yeah it is what were they
doing
what do you mean my parents
your
parents
well my parents they wanted to have a
boy so they had my brother
and then my sister was just because they
went with another kid
so she was an accident no no she wasn't
an accident she was definitely a planet
wait why do you know they were
definitely playing
and my grandma looked at us so she was
like oh wanted him well this show we are
[ __ ] yeah we are don't come in here
we're gonna have another terrible
punjabi accent right oh that was an
accident
we have a sparky
he's almost
no i'm just all irish i get that all the
time
yeah he's a future cop
yeah i shake my beard into a mustache
and it's all topping have you ever like
have you ever considered like motive
caleb is going to go on a date with
colin soon to talk yeah
he really wants to say it again caleb in
things again for you
saw it twice over it's [ __ ] correct
no i'll expect you to go again
connor
took over my entire life have you
thought do you have a
profession in your head of like if she
gets so south i'll just be that
um
[Music]
yeah
i mean i i cut hair but i don't have a
license
you know so it's like um yeah now we did
it texas
has somebody let you tattoo them
oh expedience they're like oh you can do
whatever you want they're already
they don't give a [ __ ]
this is what people do if they don't
have a college degree how does this make
you feel if you're only such degenerates
i'm a bit uncomfortable
i'm a firm believer like the five people
you surround yourself with are what kind
of components you're making
yeah it was funny because like
everybody's 500 people lined with the
weak link like i'm the one playing in
the other way
what is your boyfriend in
going to med school this july
i don't know he's going to corporate
long distance huh london sounds yeah no
she could run on top anyway
well i was trying to lay some brick in
your [ __ ] right now
sorry he's gonna be a doctor what's his
specialty no he's gonna be in med school
yeah med school so like i guess you
decide like
he doesn't know yet but you are
emergency probably gonna be an ob gyn
you guys have a long eight years ahead
of that [ __ ] sucks
like i know you guys are gonna be a lot
richer you're gonna have a comfortable
life but like i'm not looking forward to
the next eight years of your life i
think it'll be fine no it's not i dated
a guy
all through residency and it was bad he
didn't know how to listen to my feelings
he was very self-important and
saving lives he was saying yeah he
wouldn't be like oh someone died on the
table today
want to watch gamers grounds i was like
sure game of thrones was very big when i
dated it
i mean i don't know we'll see i was
going to deal with him having his pager
go off at 2 am and you're like god damn
it i'll be in houston he'll be in fort
worth
we'll be living in our best lives he'll
be doing this thing while we do my thing
okay it's really good to like i think
it's good to be like your individual
person live your life you don't need to
depend on someone else's
i'm sorry no that's what i'm saying what
did you send i said the there's a huge
sick population in houston and dallas or
they go to
gurdwara which is like our temple or
sikh temple we have like four to five in
houston and then a few like multiple in
dallas i think austin has like three
what do you guys do there like do you
guys sing because there's a lot of
singing involved in my [ __ ] are you
atheist what are you atheists me yeah
he made a comment about that
oh yeah you know i'm for sure
yeah i'm not i'm not a gay christian
that'd be [ __ ] terrible
you know god just got that one thing
yeah it was that was shellfish and uh he
just really he really liked that we uh
fashioned or something i don't know
i don't think our conversation will go
very far then so
no i was wondering if you guys said like
if it's similar to like the
process that the i went for three times
a week uh
growing up christian so i was wondering
what
you guys do with is the same
uh yeah i mean you just pray we have
like meditation there's pens everything
like just like the exact same it's yeah
it's very spiritual there's no i don't
think anything like
like it's not very scripted you have
like a your version of lord i left your
name online
lord i love to see your praises
[Music]
[Music]
i
my husband's an altar boy until he was
19.
he altered back you referred me i think
that's a year too long it's an altar
child i think that's nine years
he was 17 for the outgoing facial hair i
have actually been concerned that he
might be mentally [ __ ]
how big are his cams
so how did you meet your uh boyfriend
um i went to the team who was he taught
or with a m
and
yeah two and a half hours he wasn't in
the tv show he knows uh you guys just
love traveling huh yeah
like i don't like something here
i think i travel like three out of my
four weekends in a month
and this weekend this weekend we're in
austin we're shooting
so yeah we came from houston we came up
to fredericksburg we were at cisco home
to houston today decided today we got
into this company
yep yeah where's the coolest place
you've ever been where's your favorite
place on earth uh prague
yeah
really
it's all in uncle this far away you know
and you're trying to people that are not
convenient to get to yeah
i live on the other side
[Music]
bedroom on riverside and i can't go to
work last week because there was
gunfights
so rent's pretty cheap
in my math discovery
so what do you think about colin what do
you think you could improve for the next
day
the next date yeah
i don't think you need to tell everyone
about your shortcomings i think like
twice first of all that's my biggest
birth
second all their shortcomings when it's
just my life
begins conversations with weaknesses i
think it's very important to talk about
your strengths the warrior weaknesses
okay my calves are [ __ ] kids
perfect jesus christ you're not as old
as [ __ ]
or he was before he hasn't done whole 63
is the new
60s there's like a 20-year-old
with a hairline 20 year old hairline
i don't know
as long as he counts his hair
what are your top strengths
yeah like what would you what would you
recommend colin start with
or colin or for me um i guess you start
show show him how it's done and maybe he
gives it a go
i just told you 10 seconds ago that i'm
like i start with my weaknesses and then
i grab my strengths which is why i
recognize that he does this thing he
just said to give him a [ __ ] house
nice all right what you're gonna have a
long-term relationship i'm single there
we go i can only start my weaknesses
that'd be awesome i mean you're alive
for the next eight years so it's gonna
[ __ ] suck
i'll thank you mister yeah
you don't care and what day is your top
date i mean i don't could describe any
person yes
like my ideal yeah
just anybody who doesn't live on
riverside
yeah that's pretty interesting honestly
that's great probably maybe a degree i
don't know i'm not a com major not me
yeah that's a [ __ ] you can't expect more
than what you have to give hey hey
that's so true at all yeah
i think i respect the world
she has a finance major show so she's
investing in this med school stumor
[Music]
hard worker that's one
have you ever thought about doing a
whole fans
do you know what only fans only fan she
hasn't even been on tinder
oh i don't need the money i just don't
know it's not sexual freedom it's not
about the money
i do it for the love of the game
they're out there i go outside every day
uh that's one of my things i
have you have you tried grounding
therapy
grounding i do tapping
[Music]
yes
[Music]
yeah you think that if i go barefoot
i'll stop my only fantasy
that you would have like uh you'd
probably be happier internally no
internally i assume that i'll feel
better if i have an only dance because
i'm being filled internally
what let's see
where
no no no he's for the other
it's a real
hawaiian barbecue type situation you
know
they got a big brother that's right
that's right
this is a cop
donut
would you ever you know go on a triple
date with college you guys want to see
tom after this
[Music]
you don't like watching movies i don't
like watching movies i didn't talk about
stories
without your shoes on
ambition yeah it's been called ground
wings
and really do you really like it you'd
actually be happier in life if you did
it
up for calling with municha
they rendered david
and she's going back to her boyfriend
colin
you have your man
still gonna go see another date tonight
like colin has seen top guns 17 times
uh we got
dylan jarbo
coming up
scowling comedian dylan germans
and someone just scribbled in punjabi on
this
what the [ __ ] is this
someone's making a mockery
all right
let's keep it up
her boyfriend has her terrible
handwriting he must be a doctor
a friend with a story well i'm gonna be
with dylan turbo
he's pulling out the chair on a
gentleman they're both breadth of mind
what's up hi what's your name cynthia
i'm dylan nice to meet you i'm very
awkward to be here where do you live at
i'm from the bay in california are you
visiting
[Music]
is
his name is waffles
do you take him on the box i recently
fostered him
yes
let's take some slime
so
where are you guys this is like a
[ __ ] um software florida
jacksonville florida never been
okay
red flag
[Music]
and stuff i'm just here i was just
leaving with those two in november
really yeah would you say
uh
is
there's no way he would have gone that
close if he was in the relationship
so why don't you just like scoot closer
without announcing that you're going to
do it you know i think me too
just
he's like i'm going to get closer oh no
no he's been in the past yeah
dylan this is on camera please don't
mean to yourself on youtube right now
it's okay let's go watch me yeah
thank you
punjabi or bengali
they're not mutually exclusive
i'm i was raised
but i'm not pajama
you're not punjabi
do you have a
job oh it's up there questionable
yeah i do have shots yeah oh [ __ ] of
course
hey what do you do for a while i'm a
neuroscience researcher
and i'm a nurse
i'm a neurologist
a researcher yes and what's wrong with
the gerber's brain
it's from florida
dylan what's the most florida thing
you've done in austin
off the ground i swam in the river here
uh when i knew you shouldn't have and i
got
armed herpes it was not good don't swim
with the river here guys
do you want to get closer to him now or
oh she listened to me like honestly
wait what did you get
i swim in that river all the time
yeah don't do it
red it's
color in my skin
oh
oh so we were at an airbnb but the guy
was kind of whacked so we had to leave
yeah so they have more
no but they didn't have ac so heat
stroke hey
oh [ __ ] it all comes together was it a
town lake
it wasn't a lakeland i don't know
what sort of research thing
okay what kind of research is i feel
like that was a very interesting thing
she said we're all like well cool are
you [ __ ]
sorry we're going to bring your
neuroscience down to which color
kindergarten
okay so you want to know what kind of
research it is yeah um
well i'm doing a couple things so i'm
studying cognitive neuroanatomy so it's
like looking at structures in the brain
and how they predict function and i'm
also looking at um neuroplasticity and
brain damage folks interesting we bring
another guy out here
jacksonville florida guys
hey florida's beautiful there's beer's
got some good water
and all the people
do you uh drive a furious still or did
you switch over to tesla
i used to drive a prius i actually had
so many hydro intestines
it's called san francisco public
transportation
i mean it's pretty good
yeah if you have the money for it yeah i
have a tesla
i don't think uh colin o'meara is going
to be able to afford what lane grits out
there got great tasks too
[Music]
yeah they're bulging out of your pants
those are some great caps lovely sorry i
i did it i didn't
i didn't even
i wouldn't put the chad's tattoos
a lot of people that look like you are
doing horrible [ __ ] in the world
not iraq
but uh hopefully maybe once you know the
school you staying here
in long term
no
it's too hot
i'm from jacksonville from the same
neighborhood as leonard skinner
and it's
that's that's why i acted the way i did
just now that's there we're just just
saying
triumphs or anything do you live in
austin
yeah i do i do i live in riverside as
well i've seen oh
[Music]
do you listen to him brave sorry i'm
gonna get
into this i love the podcast do you guys
listen to him
color is yours
have you seen that no oh god we met four
indians and three out of four of them
have been in euro or in the medical
field so
it's uh i'm not i'm not gonna be a
doctor his life's way harder than mine
oh poor guy yeah it's gonna be a doctor
your next eight years dude
[Music]
it's eight oh you're not gonna do
residency
kind of
dr you're gonna be certain
okay i know what er means maybe what are
you
yeah you guys are the [ __ ] worst
you'll go in there and you're like i
think i think i'm gonna die but like
yeah i'll probably just take some i've
improved and rest okay here's a thousand
dollar [ __ ] charge i'm the worst
yeah
health prison is good
okay i'll look at loser
sandia and uh dylan really hitting it
off or
uncovering the secrets of our healthcare
system
so what do you uh what do you do uh you
you like look at mri scans and [ __ ]
show yeah pretty much well i look at
scans move push them through a pipeline
extract
structural features do statistical
analyses drop conclusions and write
papers what do you mean by shoving them
through a pipeline it's like a virtual
thing so basically you take the scans
and then it deconstructs the data and
then
it takes
numbers from it
it's like digital marketing digital
design
um
dylan jarvo what do you do for work
um
i remember she's a neuro researcher so
i'm a neuro
bank american employee
stinks a lot during his shift and um
you know i i'm
around
tired
yeah it's like what you do with brains
but with money
do you push those through pipelines too
yeah i do i don't pay attention to a lot
but
when they're only wanting to exist
so you're the person that's the the bank
teller your bank teller no no i'm not a
bank teller i just do it on the internet
i just do it on the internet they're
there
i pay attention i do it
you work for a big way you look like
someone who
so how's dating in san francisco are
there a lot of autistic people we don't
know what that's like in austin
i don't know if this is like my
generation thing or if it's a san
francisco thing but everyone claims they
have alters and radiation or both so
it gets me away with a lot you know i
can be rude and it's like yeah you
they went to the zoo have you seen it
yes
what's the same at the zoo and they were
just talking about the owls and they're
like they could rotate the end 360
degrees and they're both just sitting
there
and she's just standing us uh should we
go see the lion
my favorite animal
like to look at yeah
to look at like uh probably humans
and nicknames why are you looking at us
where are you
[Music]
haha did you want to tell us your
favorite internet
i love walruses because
needy and craig they have bad teeth
they have bad teeth
bad facial fixtures
which is how it is yeah is that true are
they actually very good to you
i mean
in nature yeah they do
this is more like love on the t-mobile
what do you mean they have bad teeth
if a human had those teeth you would
make fun of them
coming through if you're like yeah
virgin right really wanna watch you do
not think that
huh
you would see a guy walking around with
straight up vampire teeth and you would
think that guy is a virgin that would be
your first thought i would think he's a
virgin until salt and
no longer but yeah no i would think that
that's bad
what do you guys think americans know
sandia what's your favorite animal i
said humans
yeah they've been like for real like in
my books
it's a good question
um
i've been into snakes lately
i think those are cool
no it still hasn't she dated me before
you can't choose where you're born if he
could he wouldn't have chose
jacksonville who's your favorite
floridian
oh me oh
jeffrey dahmer versus house oh no no no
no
he's not from florida
no he's not he's not nevermind he made
his name in florida
it's not going to be bert crunch for
either
[Music]
let's go with uh
who's your favorite san francisco
oh look there's a good answer here it's
from san francisco back germany
[Music]
childish gambia he's from oakland though
i don't know
he's donald lover
he's familiar he's close
yeah he's cool so you're a liberal
you're vaccinated yeah absolutely okay
how many vaccines have you had
oh
like total or just no i just took over
one because i'm wondering because people
ask me for my vaccine cards like i got
that two years ago yeah wasn't still
working why are you still thinking i
don't care about that [ __ ] i got my two
pfizers and i got a booster but then i
still got copic but you know it's cool
are you gonna get the nova banks
no gosh i mean is that what's the what's
the accepted vaccine culture right how
are you supposed to get it uh yes we see
that
this request is happening
all right the test is
sometimes it's like one of those things
where i think there's so many benefits
to having a vagina but like um
tighter pants
but
i
i sometimes worry they scare me a lot
i'm telling that such that's why it is
let's unpack that i'll come right here
i'm looking actually if you're willing
to drive that boat okay i will answer
all your questions i'm nervous that
there
is going to be lint or dirt in there oh
you don't think dicks are dirty though
no but but there's a very small hole
what's your favorite cheese
oh yeah egg cheese is but uncircumcised
though that's not the date over
what the
date over i don't know
we're using your date to find out why
cultivates vaginas
sorry she's very interesting first yeah
what sparked that i guess i have a
texture phobia have you ever seen those
pictures and see if you have a texture
phobia vaginas don't have well i mean
there's so many textures
but so do penises
the balls dude penises no penises
i'm sorry we're gonna have to take a
poll everybody shows
this is a different
connection
what do you think uh
i think hurt what's that what do you
think dylan's texture is on his penis
like joe rogan's head on his penis
that's a great question yeah shiny maybe
like uh like a buzz cut maybe the shape
of a question mark
have you ever seen one with perimony's
disease speaking of rhodes parodies
disease
i've never seen one i've seen one live
and i laughed i said that's a wildly
dick and he was like whoa dude
sure
well they can make it work
it was do you know what it is
disease is when you get hit in the dick
and it's scar tissue form so that when
it gets erect it bends really hard to
the and you decide to be born with it
you can also be born with it
yeah
i don't know that
i think so yeah i think it's genetic
it's i think it's a genetic condition
isn't it i thought it was too bad i
studied communications
and actually i thought perroni is a very
funny name for him too yeah sounds like
a pizza yeah
um yeah i mean that's a different
texture i think uh dylan's penis is
probably it's got like short stubby
pubic hair
and uh yeah it's probably uh
it's humidity from florida
who's the biggest fish that sorry who's
the biggest fish that ever got away like
the date that you're like i wish i had
just
really spent the time to really catch
that fish
it's like one like who's the guy that
you wish you were still dating
up to you was like hey do you want to be
first you're the biggest one that ever
got away from me and i'm going to say
that's all my friends
and the fish that got away from me
i guess we're not talking about actual
fish of florida idiot
i
think this fish that got away from me is
my favorite thing you ever say
i think he was just talking about the
texture of her vagina
fish actually i think was pretty
offensive uh but now gay people are
bringing it back we call everything fish
now
yo what's up my fish
yeah
i want to suck dicks yeah
we could say that you blend wrong
let's go dancing together you know how
areas feel about raw fish
uh
so dylan what's uh what's something that
you could say to sandia right now that
might uh
um
microprocessor
uh but what's something that you can say
to satya right now like maybe you know
you know something about a culture like
maybe you can compliment her
i'm really looking at
wordle you're very intelligent
i think you're very intelligent i know a
lot of intelligent people watch that
so yeah they they tune in every week
and
you know what you're too good for me i'm
this is never going to work
[Music]
and you know and that's good for you
that's good for you
there you go let's look at this
that
would you say to dylan and keep him from
committing suicide saying josh
you did great he didn't agree he did
great
what a series of dates we saw any
party words
you know just try i'll be again okay
just you know put it on take it out you
especially you need to get out there
okay
not you her
jasmine jess
no no she needs to get out there
yeah try going bare feet this time yeah
you'll be happier you'll be happy
hell yeah have you guys ever kissed
this is gonna have to love that yeah
well happy pride everybody
build up for calls and download very fun
comedian and you can check him out all
over the often
uh my name is holland stan we do this
every sunday thank you guys so much for
coming and have a good night thank you
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
you